Just over a year ago, I made a video about the
cycling mechanic. That video featured a brief
history of the mechanic and associated decks as
well as a discussion of why I dislike a particular
commander printed for the mechanic a few years
ago. That video also features a brief description
of my own cycling deck—a Sharuum deck built around
the card Astral Slide. That deck has endured more
so than basically any other I’ve built—it’s the
only deck built before I started making YouTube
videos that both still gets played regularly
and also hasn’t changed dramatically. However,
the process of building it was also way different
than that of the other decks I’ve built. My decks
broadly tend to be less synergy-focused and
more play-pattern focused, with deck dynamics
being unusual but the cards themselves being
often somewhat more generic budget staples
rather than coming from a particular synergy
package. This deck was a massive exception
to that—every card was meticulously
chosen to perform hyper-specific roles
and mesh with as many other cards as possible.
For that reason, this deck has ended up being
easily my most difficult deck to build, thrusting
me well outside my normal comfort zone of deck
building. I actually left the deck unchanged
for about a year starting in mid-late 2023,
purely because it was functioning okay and I
was terrified that any changes I haphazardly
made would lead to the deck falling apart, its
mysterious special sauce getting tainted. However,
late last year I decided it was finally time
to update the deck, both adding newly printed
cards and smoothing out a handful of longtime
issues, and with the success I’ve enjoyed with
the deck since then I figured I should give
a full overview of how I built the deck,
what makes it work, and what it says
about how we as EDH players build decks.
To start with, let’s talk about the origins of
the deck. The starting point for building it
was browsing a card gallery of Onslaught cards and
having a couple particular cards stand out to me.
One of these was Astral Slide, a three mana white
enchantment that flickers a creature whenever a
card is cycled, and this offers an effective way
to reuse ETBs and temporarily remove opposing
creatures. The other card was Oversold Cemetery, a
two mana black enchantment that returns a creature
from its controller’s graveyard to their hand on
each of their upkeeps as long as there are four
or more creatures in that graveyard. This effect
can act as a recursion engine enabled by cycling,
and can also be used simply to keep up Astral
Slide fodder. From there, I decided that I also
wanted blue, since that’s a color that shares a
lot of synergy elements with what I was building,
and which also gives access to a nice range of
commanders. After a brief commander hunt, I ended
up settling on Sharuum as an Esper commander with
an impactful graveyard-oriented ETB. These three
cards alone already paint a decently clear picture
of the sort of deck I was going to be building—an
ETB-centered cycling deck with artifact and
graveyard subthemes, some key enchantments,
and enough creatures to get Oversold Cemetery
online. If that sounds specific, it’s because
it is! Immediately a handful of challenges
presented themselves, different conditions
that my deck would need to fulfill in order to be
even remotely functional. For one, the deck needs
a lot of cycling cards for purposes of reliable
Astral Slide triggers—I ended up deciding that
a high 30s count was about right and have stuck
with around that number through various iterations
of the deck. Secondly, a reasonably high creature
count for Oversold Cemetery, at least 30. Thirdly,
a way to find key cards—the deck relies on Astral
Slide for its gameplan and there are only three
cards that perform the function of Astral Slide,
so some tutors to find them will be very helpful.
Finally, the deck needs ways to get cards
into its graveyard, with draw-and-discard
effects seeming most appropriate. I found that
7 was basically as low as I could go for these.
Okay, so this is immediately placing a lot of
requirements on the deck, with the high-30s
count of cycling cards being the most rigorous.
Even if we consider the 14 available cycling
lands in Esper colors and run all of them—which I
do—that still means we’re looking at less than 40
available slots for nonland, non-cycling cards.
What this means is that cards need to perform
multiple roles, or else be utterly fantastic at
their main job. For ETB creatures, the mages were
a great starting point—3 mana 2/2 wizards that
tutor for an artifact of a specific mana cost—and
Sphinx Summoner was a similarly sweet inclusion.
Tribute Mage finds Fluctuator, which is a key card
for the deck since it gives great mana savings
on cycling back-to-back cards, but aside from
that these cards mostly find secondary cards for
the deck, so what about tutors to find the deck’s
key enchantments, Astral Slide and co? Since I
was already in Esper colors, a natural choice
was Zur, a creature who can tutor out low cost
enchantments whenever he attacks. Conveniently,
he’s also a Wizard, which brings me to a key
piece of this deck—Wizardcycling. There are
two different Wizardcycling cards in existence,
which end up being solidly costed instant speed
tutors that also count as a cycle for Astral Slide
purposes. As an added bonus, one of these is a
flash creature, which is grabbable with the newly
printed MDFC Waterlogged Teachings—I got a chance
to do this a couple weeks back, and there’s
nothing like the rush of tutoring to find a
tutor to find a tutor to find an Astral Slide.
Now, this might seem a bit deranged—and yeah,
it kinda is. But it also points to a key facet
of this deck—its status as a “toolbox” deck.
This phrase means that the deck has a network
of conditional tutors that can each find a
certain selection of cards the deck might
need in various situations. For example,
the deck’s Wizardcycling cards can find four
tutors, as well as an excellent recursion
card and three cards for purposes of countering
opposing spells and abilities. Worth pointing out
is that all of these work with Astral Slide in
some way, gaining additional value off of Slide
or finding Slide or triggering Slide. Delving
deeper into the toolbox, the most useful of
the three artifact mages, Treasure Mage, can find
lifegain, a finisher, multiple types of removal,
and a couple value sources, and the fact that
it’s repeatable with Astral Slide is a big deal
since it lets me load up on top end threats I can
discard and then Sharuum back out. Sphinx Summoner
can find most of the stuff that Treasure Mage
can since most of them are artifact creatures,
and it can also find a board wipe and an angsty
bird. In addition to this selection of conditional
tutors, there’s also a couple cards from one of
my favorite mechanics in all of Magic—Transmute!
These are cards that allow their controller to pay
three mana and discard them to tutor for a card of
the same mana cost. I originally had a three mana
enchantment tutor, Idyllic Tutor, in this deck,
but honestly a three mana transmute card does a
similar job giving me access to key enchantments,
and also gives me access to other useful things
like the recursion of Tameshi, the graveyard
hate of Boggart Trawler, the graveyard feeding
of Thirst for Knowledge, and so on, as well as
being a very funny counterspell on top of it all.
The cumulative effect of all of these individual,
highly conditional tutors is striking—I have six
other cards that can lead me to one of my three
key Astral Slide enchantments or one of my top-end
artifact creatures, and I have five other cards
each that can lead me to Fluctuator or Oversold
Cemetery. I also have a lot of cards that can
be grabbed by just one or two tutors, meaning that
this deck ends up being a massive web of different
tutors which each prompt me with interesting
decisions to make. This quantity of tutors
might sound objectionable to some, but, well,
hear me out. I’ll get back to that objection.
Part 2—Play Patterns
With the key cards and an overview
of the toolbox out of the way,
let’s get to how this deck plays in practice.
Early turns are spent sculpting a hand, ramping,
and beginning to assemble value engines. There
are a lot of cards which can be played out early
and then Astral Slid later to reuse the ETBs—the
artifact mages, my sad robots, my angsty bird,
and so on. The early game can also be a time
to feed the graveyard—being able to Sharuum
out a big artifact on turn 5 or 6 can offer
a nice tempo swing that forces my opponents
onto the back foot and gives me room to develop my
advantage. I talk about the deck in terms of tempo
and advantage because this deck is a control deck,
through and through. You might not be able to tell
this by looking at the deck—it’s running a
relatively high creature count of 35, and its
commander is a generic artifact recursion card
from Alara block. Its quantity of counterspells,
while probably higher than average in raw terms,
is nothing crazy and consists mostly of spells
which can also either be transmuted or cycled.
It’s also not running a single conventional
board wipe—sure, there’s an incomplete wipe,
a sleep effect, a multi-creature edict, and
a couple things that reduce power and toughness
based on the amount of mana put in, but nothing
that says destroy all… anything.
So what makes this a control deck?
Fundamentally, it comes down to this deck’s
play pattern. Highlighting my deck’s Astral
Slide targets in Archidekt immediately gives an
indication of this—a big part of this deck’s game
plan is repeating value generation and removal,
and that repeated removal can be some heavy duty
hate over the course of multiple turn cycles.
More broadly, at any given moment in a game,
this deck will be balancing three different
goals—stay alive, suppress opponents, and
build value. Staying alive means keeping my life
total up and preventing opponents from winning,
suppressing opponents means taking actions
that worsen my opponents’ position in the game,
and building value means doing things that improve
my position in the game. The desirability of
working toward these goals runs from right
to left—I love to build up my own value,
I’m happy enough to take actions that slow
down opponents and make them less of a threat,
and I don’t really like needing to
spend time and resources staying alive,
but that one’s pretty unnegotiable if I want to
keep having a shot at winning a game. My chances
of winning go up and up the more I get to focus
on these right two—my ideal game is where all
of my energy can go into building up my own
engine of ETB creatures and cycling spells,
as well as neutralizing opposing engines
and threats early in their lifespan.
So that’s the biggest feature of the
deck—balancing these different elements.
Early turns are spent building resources, getting
blockers on the board, and getting ready to answer
anything my opponents are doing that is an
existential threat to my position in the game.
Since this is a toolbox deck, every suppression
tool that I don’t need to grab means a piece
of value or ramp instead, and once I have Astral
Slide in play there will often be choices between
flickering creatures that are suppressive or
defensive in some way and flickering ones that
boost my gameplan. As a result, threat evaluation
is key to keeping opponents in check without
losing too much momentum. The deck can make more
daring early plays, but these often come at the
cost of long-term value, so it’s important to
weigh the pros and cons and have follow up plays
in mind. One natural question might be, what do I
mean by follow up? How does this deck win? Well,
as with most control decks, this deck
is trying to reach a state of stability,
where it has a lot of agency over the state of the
game. This state will look different depending on
the game because different tools will be required
to keep different opposing decks in check. Here
are a handful of things that might be true in the
end-game scenario, though, in no particular order.
A lot of mana, either through land counts
built up by flickered robots, or powerstone
tokens that can pay for cycling costs.
A healthy hand of cards, especially one
that includes multiple cycling cards as well as
things like counterspells and recursion pieces.
Nimble Obstructionist is especially nice, as it
deals with a lot of pesky abilities that most
control decks don’t have a way to handle.
Utility permanents that help keep the deck
chugging along, such as engines that build
value turn over turn and permanents that
can disrupt opposing attempts to regain footing
A high life total that puts me out of range of
dying to any number of common threats, as well
as enough blockers to handle sudden attacks.
Once enough of these conditions are met, winning
the game from there is usually straightforward.
A key type of creature for this deck is medium to
large fliers, a type which includes the commander,
and these constitute a decent threat to life
totals given enough time. As long as I’m able
to give them that time, they’ll usually win me the
game. However, there will be some games where an
opponent will get a very high life total, or
alternatively will be in a highly threatening
position with a normal life total, so I run a
couple finisher cards as well. One I alluded
to earlier—Magister Sphinx is a fantastic card,
giving me a way to rapidly burst down a problem
player. This can be extremely sudden for my
opponents—on the second main phase before my turn,
I can play a draw/discard effect to discard
Magister Sphinx, then cycle something to flicker
Sharuum and bring back Magister Sphinx, turning
an opponent’s life total to 10. Then on my turn, I
can cycle a couple more things to clear out flying
blockers before one-shotting the problem opponent,
who could have been at any life total a single
turn earlier. The other finisher I run is Herald
of the Forgotten—this can bring back any
of my 14 cycling creatures in my graveyard,
and importantly it can also bring back any
of my 14 cycling lands. This is great—it’s
usually a burst of creatures to contest the
board, but also a burst of ramp to fuel my
later turns. This second part is so big for
the deck because the creatures don’t even
need to be impactful—even if it’s just some extra
blockers, it also gives me a burst of resources,
fueling both my “staying alive”
and “building value” goals.
So that’s basically the deck—it’s a highly
flexible, cycling-based control deck with
graveyard, artifact, and wizard packages woven
throughout. There are a lot of more common play
patterns, such as flickering a key creature
like Angel of the Ruins or Treasure Mage with
Astral Slide, but also a lot of much more niche
play patterns. For example, if I have a lot of
mana and opposing value is mostly based around
creatures being untapped, Monstrosity of the
Lake can be flickered every turn to keep opposing
stuff permanently slept. This isn’t a common play,
but the fact that Monstrosity has Islandcycling
makes it a low-investment card to include in
the deck. Another niche play is using Oversold
Cemetery and Nimble Obstructionist as a stifle
engine, which can keep a key opposing effect that
triggers once a turn suppressed. A couple of other
interesting plays—Tameshi can return MDFCs
and cycling lands to hand to be used later,
and Currency Converter can protect key
artifacts from sorcery speed graveyard
hate. For somewhat saucier play, Perplex can be
followed up with another counterspell to bait an
opponent into discarding their hand for three
mana in exchange for absolutely no benefit.
I just keep on discovering new ways
to play this deck, and that fact also
provides a great advantage when it comes to
resiliency. No matter what my opponents remove,
or how my opponents slow me down, I have a way to
play around it and keep building advantage in some
way or other. The recursion suite of the deck is
quite robust, and this is also a rare deck that
actually has good access to stifle effects to deal
with graveyard hate. Even without its graveyard,
the deck can still build value with Astral Slide
effects, since the deck’s high density of cycling
cards means that all that’s needed to have a
value engine is an Astral Slide style enchantment
and an ETB creature. At least one of these two
things—graveyard-based value building and Astral
Slide-based value building—is usually necessary to
keep up, but those two things can take a countless
number of different forms, and there are lots
of smaller packages riddled throughout the deck
that can pose decent threats all on their own. The
fact that there are so many different themes that
are so interconnected in the deck means that
pivots are much easier than they would be in
most other decks. The fact that my core card is
Astral Slide means that I have a way to resist
creature board wipes and a way to break parity
on creature-based stax effects on hand almost
always. The fact that most of my game actions
are abilities rather than spells also insulates
me against a lot of conventional hate for fiddly
control decks. The fact that my deck runs lots
of unique effects and conditional tutors means I
can simply avoid tutoring for a specific effect if
there’s currently hate for it lurking around. The
fact that the deck derives its consistency from
filtering and tutors allows Sharuum to play a
more supporting role, to simply be cast for a
burst of value before hanging around as a beater
until some Astral Slide shenanigans are ready to
happen. The wide array of different play paths
and effects in this deck is equally beneficial
in making this deck resilient to hate and
in making this deck interesting to play.
Part 3—Tutors
Tutors, though—I did say I’d get back to them, and
now is as good a time as any to address the many
tutoring crimes of this deck. Tutors are a subject
of contention within the casual EDH community,
with many players seeing them as a sweaty cEDH
tool that goes against the spirit of the format.
Other players simply see them as boring, making
decks more streamlined and formulaic rather than
offering the wide diversity of plays that EDH
should be all about. I don’t think anybody is
necessarily wrong for their feelings about
this—tutors can be a formulaic tool for the
sweat lords of the world. Anybody who has
played against a Natural Ordered Craterhoof
or a Demonic Tutored infinite combo can attest
to this—tutors can feel bland and deflating,
just an extra copy of a powerful game-ending
spell. It might be interesting to interrogate
why they’re more bland and deflating than that
power-card simply being drawn and played—my hunch
is that it comes down to lucky topdecks simply
being an accepted part of the game—but still,
these sorts of plays don’t make people feel good,
and I don’t think they’re wrong for that. I myself
don’t really play unconditional tutors, tutors
that can find any card in a player’s library,
because I don’t find them very interesting. At the
same time, the tarring of tutors as a universally
boring tool is a bit wrongheaded. Tutors can
find the easy win, but they can also find all
sorts of things, such as… a centerpiece
engine that all sorts of other cards can
build off of in cool and textured ways. I hear
people say that tutoring up a card every game,
having a “secret commander” if you
will, goes against the spirit of EDH,
but if having easy access to a card, playing
it every game, and coordinating other cards
to work nicely with it goes against the spirit of
EDH, then I really have no choice but to conclude
that EDH goes against the spirit of EDH. Pack it
up folks, the format was doomed from the start.
No, tutors are not inherently boring, and the
things that make them boring or not boring are
what you do with them, same as any other type of
card. In my case, conditional tutors actively make
my deck more interesting. Tutors allow me to run
a greater variety of cards, cards that interact in
cool and complex ways, and it allows this because
tutors improve my ability to find different sorts
of cards from within my deck. There are some
cards that just aren’t great without at least
some support from my core cards, and without
tutors for those core cards these wouldn’t be
good enough. There are other types of cards that
perform a specific role, but who can’t fill this
role fully enough without tutors to find them.
Absent ways to find my key cards, I’d be forced
to run more generic cards, cards that are good
by themselves and that fit into a smaller number
of synergy roles rather than the rich tapestry of
synergy that I’m able to fit into my deck. Through
the power of tutors I’m able to run very little
generic ramp, generic draw, generic removal, and
so on—my card choices get to be more interesting
and more specific to my deck because I have a
suite of conditional tutors to help me put things
together, and that makes my deck more interesting!
As with most decks my gameplan builds off a few
central node cards, but there’s a ton of diversity
in what things actually end up looking like
because of how niche and creative my card choices
were able to be. This isn’t to say that tutors
inherently make a deck interesting—there are decks
I find less interesting that run a lot of tutors,
and 4 of my 6 current decks that I play regularly
run none at all, and I like to think they’re
not too boring. But having or not having tutors
will impact the options that a deck can go with,
and going tutor-less will often mean sacrificing
either power or specificity—you’ll end up with
a deck that’s simpler and runs more generic
cards—as the non-tutoring 4 of my 6 decks do to
some extent—or you’ll end up with a deck that
doesn’t play smoothly and might not be able to
keep up and make its cool plays in a lot of games.
Part 4 — Conclusion
As I said at the start of this video, this
was a deck outside my normal comfort zone of
deckbuilding, both for the process of originally
building it and for the process of updating it.
There are a lot of potential reasons for this, but
the biggest one is that this deck pushes beyond
the bounds of the levels of synergy that I and
most other EDH players are used to using. Running
a bunch of different synergy packages in the
same deck can be tricky, and doing it elegantly
requires putting an intense degree of focus on
points of connectivity and places where different
archetypes overlap. As a result, building this
deck was basically a piecemeal project of adding
different packages and cards that fit the rigorous
requirements of the deck. I started with the two
key cards and added Sharuum once I decided on
my color identity and that I wanted a commander
with a powerful ETB. The mages were added because
they were artifact synergies that were also ETBs,
and once I found Wizardcycling as a way to
connect cycling to these wizards, I was able
to loop in Zur as a tutorable way to find my
key enchantments. Tameshi was pulled into this
Wizardcycling package as a way to recur my two
key card types, and Hall of Heliod’s Generosity
and Geier Reach Sanitarium were added as
land-based ways to recur and loot, respectively,
once it was clear that landcycling had me covered
for colorfixing. Terisiare’s Devastation made it
in as a lovely ramp-boardwipe pairing in place
of a hard wipe, and a few different MDFCs ended
up being a great way to compress my slots even
further to squeeze just that extra little bit
of utility out of everything, as well as working
well with Tameshi. Even late in the process I’m
still finding new ways to tighten up synergies
just that extra little bit—Ertai Resurrected
was a recent addition to this deck as a card that
counters spells and removes creatures as an ETB,
and is a wizard on top of it all. I still don’t
know if I’ve reached the most optimized and
cohesive possible version of this deck—there
are so many cards that could possibly work
in the deck depending on the matchups I find
myself in, more than I have time to test all of.
I also don’t know if I’ve found the perfect
blend of interaction yet—recent playtesting has
had board wipes feeling a bit underrepresented
and soft counter-locks on noncreature spells
feeling overrepresented, but I have no idea
if that pattern will hold in the long term.
What you can take away from this is that building
a hyper-connected synergy machine like this is a
slow, creeping, iterative process. The lower
hanging fruits can be found from a scryfall
search in an afternoon, tossing in all of the
best cards with a particular word or phrase,
but if you’re trying to weave together a bunch of
different things under tight constraints it will
be more of a process. The most important part of
this process is finding nodes to build off of that
pull different elements together—Wizardcycling
was a big one in the case of this deck—and
then including only cards that can perform
multiple roles or that perform their primary
role fantastically well. In this deck that
meant viciously scrutinizing any card that
wasn’t an artifact with a fetchable mana
value, a cycling card, a key enchantment,
a Wizard, or an ETB creature. What survived that
scrutiny? Not many cards—we’ve got some looters,
some multi-modal tutors, and a small handful of
best-in-class cards. In a deck like this it’s also
important to be able to weed out cards that might
share a synergy pillar but which aren’t actually
good—as far as cycling synergies go, Curator
of Mysteries isn’t actually worth playing as
a creature basically ever, Jo Grant isn’t great
for the same reason, Drake Haven isn’t that great
outside of a go-wide creature deck, and Abandoned
Sarcophagus is an actively bad card. Likewise,
it might be tempting to load up on a bunch of
nifty Wizard synergy cards, but these aren’t
all that great either with the numbers of Wizards
the deck is running, and forcing in a wizard count
high enough to make them good would tank other
parts of the deck. Building an elaborate and
meticulous synergy machine requires restraint
above all else—you need to be able to resist
the urge to throw cards in because of a single
idealized situation you constructed in your brain.
What do cards look like in the less ideal half of
the situations you’ll be finding them in? That’s
always an important thought to cycle through, and
one that’ll save you a lot of wasted time testing
cards that realistically never had a chance
of being a permanent fixture of a deck.
The other thing you should take away from my
endeavor here is that it’s worth it to build
a deck that’s difficult to build. If the process
I described in the last few minutes sounded hard,
that’s because it was! Building a deck like
this is a challenge, but that’s also what
makes it such a gratifying exercise. Seeing the
deck actually work out after I’ve put hours into
tuning it is satisfying, and figuring out new
ways I can smooth over some rough edges in it
is also satisfying. The fact that I still have
a large maybeboard in paper and a mental list of
pivots I could try for solving various problems
is exciting, and forcing myself to engage with a
deck like this has undoubtedly made me a stronger
deckbuilder. This interlocking synergy machine
type of deck is the one I personally find hardest
to build, but your most difficult to build deck
style might be different. Whatever it is, though,
you should take a crack at it! It’s difficult to
fight back against a deckbuilding weakness,
but the resulting decks can be really cool.
That sums up the video, however I have an
announcement. It’s a birthday party! For
my discord server. Okay, what I mean to say is
I’m running a new deckbuilding challenge! That
challenge goes as follows: build a deck using one
of the following “Choose a Background” commanders:
Ellyn Harbreeze Busybody, Halsin Emerald
Archdruid, Amber Gristle O’Maul, Alora
Merry Thief, and Viconia Drow Apostate. They
can be paired with any background that appeals
to you. A top deck for each commander will be
selected and highlighted in a future video,
and judging criteria will be creativity, cohesion,
and likelihood to produce dynamic gameplan.
And—this time there’s a prize. The creator of each
of the top decks will receive a Haunted One alter,
hand-painted by my friend Mechacatten who did the
art for my channel banner and profile picture. If
that sounds up your alley, you can find more
info about the challenge in my discord server,
and you’ll want to submit a deck
by noon PST on Tuesday the 21st.
As always I want to thank my patrons for
supporting what I do here, allowing me
to make high effort videos like this one without
needing to worry too much about how they’ll fare
in the algorithm. Submissions for this month’s
deck review will run until the end of tomorrow,
so if you want to have a chance at getting your
deck reviewed by me, you can check that out. If
you want more of me and don’t want to pay money, I
was on an episode of the Magic Mirror Podcast that
should be releasing around the same time as this
video, and there I go further into my feelings
about tutors along with my two co-hosts. A link
to that is in the description. Alright, bye now.